puedo leer sus hierbas supongo este
chico los está obteniendo
reunimos a siete personas drogadas estoy
drogado estoy drogado estoy drogado
estoy drogado estoy drogado estoy
drogado se puede decir que estoy un poco
drogado dos de ellos están sobrios si el
grupo descubre quiénes son los
mentirosos se repartirán un premio en
efectivo
[Música]
si los mentirosos sobreviven ganarán
todo el premio quienes son los
impostores
vamos a empezar con una merienda
unas dos
eres no como muchos dulces
comida preferida o que les gusta beber
si es que sea que tengas cerca papas y
salsa es cierto siempre técnicos esto
sonará raro pero salchichas frías con
salsa picante no me mires así no hasta
aquí y erbes las salchichas sousas del
microondas cuando esta precocidad son
asesinadas sólo las sacas del paquete
como
perros calientes y es mejor cuando estoy
fumando porque me gusta mucho no sé por
qué qué tipo de gen cierto jugo de
manzana de naranja en cualquier tipo de
jugo que sepa bien así que está sano
verdad no comes dulce si estás quiero
decir me gusta el azúcar pero ya saben
no me gusta comer mucho yo sospechaba
sobre todo de dimitri tomaba el mando y
además no comía ninguno de los
bocadillos lo cual era raro porque había
donas de chocolate de las comerías
verdad escuché un acento si soy de
australia
y
no debería ir allí dijo que era ilegal
aquí así que eso significaba que tal vez
no tenía acceso a la hierba pero estamos
en california así que seguro que tiene
acceso a la hierba no tengo idea para
ser sincero bueno continúa amigo
de acuerdo sólo iba a decir que hagamos
algunas preguntas para conocernos mejor
cómo se drogaron antes de esto fumando
lo que hago es fumarme un blend sabe en
un blue no combinado estaba en una
sesión de música de eso vivo mis amigos
y yo compartimos unos cuantos estuvo
bien estuve en mi auto drogándome con
genial unas dos horas antes de ella
también lo hice en el auto de mi novia
no puedo conducir se drogaron antes de
venir aquí o yo puedo leer sus cambios y
la hierba supone puedes oler cambia
justo antes pero si estamos pateando
vuelo lleva por aquí no voy a mentir
toda mi ropa huele a hierba porque fumo
en mi habitación tiene sentido supe que
dmitri estaba drogado desde que estaba a
su lado el olor era
y muy fuerte
todos pueden identificarse con este caso
están muy drogados venas son mascotas y
tienen una y piensan que morirá algún
día entonces se pone triste es súper
vista es triste pero
me miran fijamente y dicen
tienen algo que decir
[Risas]
[Música]
y
te extrañaré gracias honestamente me
sorprendió bastante cuando me echaron sé
que huelo a hierba no no lo sé pensé que
era obvio que él era el impostor pero
podría estar equivocado dios mío lo
siente tan bueno es su equilibrio y yo
decir estamos relajados amigos como he
dicho no estoy borracho
estamos drogados
bien lo intentaré de espalda
camino de espaldas y fue más allá justo
así justo así y justo así y voy a dar
unos pequeños pasos hacia delante
tú puedes más bien de acuerdo si sigue a
ver si puedo
caminar no me ayudó mucho a decidir si
estaban drogados o no rotación soñada de
ahorro es cómo con quién querrías
formaría en estas 24 20 en un vídeo que
saldrá toque en una canción de snoop
dogg y no me veis el de la patineta
si el de la patineta
así que fumamos un porro con él no en el
vídeo sino después tenía que hacer
este
sueño me estaba dando vibras de pastor
juvenil no fuma pero estado con personas
que lo hacen bien
es una muy buena guns y ya saben quiero
decir amigo ese es un calvo no sé quién
es todos quieren todos quieren fumar con
un calvo alguna vez
era realmente como muy coherente
me parece que era un poco engañoso
tenemos un empate
el empate es entre song
y deivid
se les dará 30 segundos se expongan su
caso estoy bien fumado fumé de mi
bonicas a poco de caldo han puesto
nombre a su bong
parece un jarrón final todos deben
nombrar su bong yo personalmente siempre
nombro mismos incluso después de
romperlos madrugue con el lumen mi auto
por dos horas justo antes de esto pensó
vamos a hacerlo durante una hora pero
llegamos a casa dos horas antes y nos
quedamos en el auto
[Música]
s
lo siento lo siento amigos están ricas
no tenía un nombre para mi pong comenten
abajo como creen que debería llamar a mi
pong porque no tengo y levanten la mano
si creen que el impostor sigue aquí y si
les gustaría seguir el juego
si lo supongo a partir de ahora por cada
vez que expulsen a alguien que no sea el
impostor se reducirá la cantidad total
del premio así lo veo siento que la cosa
era como estás drogado o está sobrio no
es si eres un meta o no si porque con su
deber a ser un fome está aquí y no estar
drogado así que creo que deberíamos
hacer otras preguntas como cuál es su
historia favorita ya están drogado y
cosas así porque creo que algunos de
ustedes no actúan tan drogados como los
demás también golpea diferente lo
comentó algunas personas
siempre me meten mi cabeza en un sofá en
medio de mi apartamento y anoche
literalmente corría alrededor de el
filmar de veces está más delgado queda
tienen ustedes podríamos decir lo bueno
o 25 25 14 22
yo tengo 20
tarjeta médica tengo mi tarjeta
tuve un accidente de auto en 2017 y
desde entonces tengo dolor de espalda
así que me dicen que mi nieta médica
estaba bastante mal usaba un collarín y
me revisaba la cadera casi rima
quienes ya vienen mejor toma tu tarjeta
médica el fue directo tenía la tarjeta y
luego los policías también estaban tras
el o imos la alarma nos preocupamos por
david por un segundo pero muy bien sepas
favoritas o
literalmente solo consumo comestibles
así que todo lo que se sativa índica
olvidar cigarrillos electrónicos y
creo
favorito
mi amigo compro uno y yo solo me fumé el
resto pero solo consumo
yo todavía amiga siento que las personas
conocen las cepas aunque no las fumen
piña expresa es una película al menos
sabes cómo prepararlo a comenzar algo
perfecto con esto todos los
espera espera
[Música]
i
lo lamento
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue aquí y si les gustaría
seguir jugando no lo sé
cuando el dinero va a ganar les dar unos
30 segundos para pensar les voy a dar
literalmente a pieza contiene 10
segundos de acuerdo pero ninguna idea no
lo sé yo realmente no siente quieren
votar o depende de usted yo no me apego
a lo que decidan los eeuu quiero mucho
si creen que el encuestador sigue aquí
si les gustaría seguir jugando levanten
los que estamos bien y no se es una
tarjeta médica hermano bien jugaremos
una ronda más si aquí esperas pero
espere espere espera tengo esta cosa de
una tarjeta en mi bolsillo así de donde
lo cuelgas exterior de la tarjeta está
en mi mente espera me parece que te
expusiste porque mi hermano fuma nik y
así es como se ve la boquilla ni
siquiera sé cómo es la última mujer eso
es como un papá don yo pero esto es de
hierba entiendo conseguiste unos aires
que en forma tenía el cigarrillo de
hierba que te dieron un cilindro como
los demás espera déjame ver la tapa
déjame ver la que detectivesco
de acuerdo si está bien qué tipo de
envoltorios usan uno crudos anulados
honestamente soy demasiado precio igual
igual
yo estaba tratando de idear escenarios
porque sentía que el impostor seguía y
se me ocurrió que si no hubiera solo un
fumador y que ya estaba diciendo todo
esto por su novio debemos todos
deberíamos decir todos los nombres sí
creo que podría más rey
lo nombró bob marley como se atrevió no
quise maldecir pero el tipo trata de ser
un fumet a como también podría llamarlos
no bong el mío es doris dörrie porque
estás interesante y me recuerda don el
mío se llama sunshine me gusta despertar
con sol
su nombre es ex esposa me lo dio un
amigo él me lo regaló eso es legítimo
porque así es como conseguía doble
graduó de la secundaria y me lo dio me
dijo mami te voy a comer otro de estos
cortes me dan el gusto
le puedes mostrar eso sin seguro sostén
[Música]
gracias chicos lo siento los aprecio yo
creo que estamos bien nos estamos
relajando levanten la mano si creen que
el impostor sigue aquí y si les gustaría
seguir jugando voy a bajar la guardia
ahora tendré problemas de confianza si
perdemos eso eso es lo que haremos
si las luces se ponen verdes significa
que eliminaron el impostor y todos
ganaron si las luces se ponen rojas
significa que el impostor sigue aquí y
perdieron
estaba pensando en ver ya saben por la
hierba y luego se puso rojo que los
impostores se rebelen en
mi historia es real es por mi mamá me
tomé un descanso por mi salud mental al
igual que para trabajar en ella sin la
hierba ya se fume una vez y fue una
experiencia horrible tuve que dedicarme
fue más que una paranoia lo que sea
simplemente no fue bueno para mí pero ha
sido parte de mi identidad que la gente
piense que estoy drogado todo el tiempo
hasta que nunca confíes en que hice algo
más no realmente es que estoy drogado lo
siento ojo vamos a
je je je je je je je je
mira voy a contarlo muy rápido para
saber cuánto tengo aquí puedo pagar el
alquiler rechazar algunos trabajos les
compraré algo de hierba les parece